a celebration and baku
of azerbaijan's victory in the 44-day
conflict with armenia
over the nagorno-karabakh region three
thousand
azeri soldiers alongside turkish
commandos
surrendered by military hardware and
weapons
a show of hard power by two countries
calling themselves one nation two states
the leaders of turkey and azerbaijan
have said the victory will unite the
turkic countries
and they said a joint proposal from
russia iran turkey
azerbaijan georgia and armenia to keep
peace in the region is feasible
if positive steps are taken on this
matter we will open our borders that are
closed
as long as these positive steps are
taken we do not have to keep the borders
closed with armenia
because we want to take the steps for
peace moreover we don't hold any grudge
against armenian people our problem is
with the leadership
azerbaijan's president ilham alive said
his country had regained its territorial
integrity
if the armenian leadership draws the
right consequences from the war
drop their unfounded claims and look
into the future they
also have a place in this platform we
are open to this
the six weeks of fighting that erupted
in nagorno-karabakh late september
killed more than 5000 people ankara was
widely accused of dispatching
mercenaries from syria
to bolster baku's army but repeatedly
denied the charge
a ceasefire deal was then brokered by
russia in early november
spurring mass celebrations in azerbaijan
and causing thousands of armenians
living in the territory to leave
armenia's prime minister nicole pacinian
faced large demonstrations
calling for his resignation for what
many called a capitulation
nearly 2 000 russian peacekeepers have
been deployed to the region on a
renewable five-year mandate
and the truth will be monitored in
azerbaijan by the turkish military
as aliyev promised to reconstruct
nagorno-karabakh
turkey and azerbaijan signed several
agreements
turkey's metro presence is seen by
azerbaijanis as a support and boost for
morale
for turkey it also paves the way for
ankara to expand its influence into the
caucasus
as their ties strengthen many experts
warn turkey's aspirations may face
resistance from moscow and aggravate
their old
fragile relationship over libya and
syria
synagogue solar elders here istanbul